hello everyone uh welcome to yet another
talk
about asynchronous programming in dotnet
so
why another talk well uh most of the
ones i've seen
uh focus on how to use tasks and usually
end up with somebody asking in that
precise situation that you didn't
describe
should i use configure weight or not and
i believe the reason for that
is that those talks focus on how to use
this
api but they don't really explain what
happens under the hood
so when faced with a new situation
you can't really extrapolate about what
you're supposed to do
this time i'm not going to talk about
how to use task
instead i'll try to break the magic and
show you what happens
under the hood and to do that we're
going to re-implement tasks
from scratch of course we won't have
time to cover
anything far from it so i'll focus
only on the subset of features uh needed
to re-implement
async await and by the end of the talk
you might still don't know whether you
need to use
a configure weight in that particular
situation
but i hope i will have given you the
tools to dig into the framework and find
the answer by yourself
so let's jump in and start by setting
a bit of vocabulary if i managed
yeah there we go uh so uh
task is the microsoft implementation of
the future and promise pattern which is
a pattern for asynchronous programming
and the way it works is that the user
code occurs in a synchronous method
and on the side of the method
immediately
a pair of objects is created a promise
and a feature
and the future is written to the client
and then a nasa clause operation
executing the background
and when it's done it uses it signals
the promise sorry which in turn
completes the future
and on client side so after calling the
method the
method returns shortly after with the
future
then the client can do other stuff on
the side and when it's ready to fetch
the result it can use the feature
to get that data to give a real world
analogy it works a bit like if you were
a pre-order stop pre-ordering some stuff
at the store so you go to the store you
pre-order they give you a voucher
and then you go back home and live your
life and a few days after
after there is a product you can go back
to the store and exchange the voucher
for the product you pre-order so that's
exactly how it works
and so in the framework uh the promise
is named tacom completion source and the
future is named task and this is the two
objects that we will re-implement during
this talk
and so for the remainder i will refer to
test completion source as promise
and task as future so
we are going to start with the most
basic implementation
of those two objects so
here is the most basic feature that we
can make
this class has an internal constructor
because we don't want user to directly
create it
and we have a very simple state it's
either completed or is not
we don't deal with exception or
cancellation we don't have time for that
and we have a simple synchronization we
have one v
text when we said completely to true we
signal the mutex
and we have a wet method to wait for it
so we can't choose by itself we also
need to
implement a promise so i'm going to copy
paste it
right there and in the promise
we wrap the future and we expose it in
the property
and we have a single method complete
which transitions the future to complete
it
so promise is our class completion
source and future
is our task and from there from the from
the user code
you can write this kind of asynchronous
method
where we immediately create a promise
start an asynchronous operation and
return the future
during the example when the asynchronous
operation completes
after one second we just complete the
promise and then on client side
we can call the asynchronous method
here we do our stuff and then
at some point we can wait on the future
and fetch the results
and so if i run it like this uh well
nothing impresses is going to happen
it's just going to wait for one second
and then we see it done
um more often than not you will want
your asynchronous
method to return some data alongside the
feature
so this is what we're going to implement
next
so we need a generic version of the
feature that we're going to call
a feature of t and we just make it
inherit from the future
and the only thing it adds is a result
property which will contain the result
of the method then we need a new promise
to manipulate it so a generic promise
so we create a promise of t
and here you might be tempted to make it
inherit from promise
but we can't do that because if we do
that
then we get the parameter less complete
method
and it means that somebody can complete
the promise without setting a result on
the future
which will lead to some consistent
states so we cannot do that
and if you think about it that's the
reason why for so long there
hasn't been a non-generic task
completion source in the dotted
framework
it's because to implement it since they
can't make one inherit from the other
they would have to duplicate the code
and so they don't want to do that
unless they have a compelling reason to
do so and
a bit of trivia the non-generic test
compression source
was merged into net core
a few days ago so it should be finally
available in dot five
so we can do that so instead we have to
copy paste
the code of the promise and here use
a generic feature instead and of course
the complete method will take a value
and then we just assign the value to the
future
so we will not take care of race
condition and this kind of stuff
because we won't have time and so now
that we have that
here we can return the future of hints
so we can create a promise of it
and we can complete the promise with the
value 42
and then from client side we can say
console.writeline a feature completed
with value
and if everything works properly then
then it should display fortitude
hopefully
oh there we go so still nothing very
impressive but you already have the
basic tools to do some async programming
but pretty quickly you will notice one
problem is that
whenever you need to fetch the value of
a feature that is
not yet completed you only well your
only way is to call the weight method
which will block the thread
synchronously
and so you will be wasting resources uh
just waiting around
which is a shame since one of the points
of asynchronous programming is pretty
easy to free
those threads when waiting for
operations so to fix that we need to add
a new api
we need to add a notification system
that allows us to subscribe to the
future
and be called back when it completes we
are going to implement
that and i go back to my future and i'm
going to add that method that we're
going to
continue with i'm going to take an
actionable feature
which is a continuation and the idea
that
whenever this future completes we are
going to call
this continuation with the future as
a as a parameter this way the
continuation can take decision
based on the status of his parents
but if we design the api like that
we will be able of course to do here
feature dot
continue it but then if we want to chain
another continuation after this one we
cannot because
our return type is void so it would be
much more convenient
to instead return the future and the
convention will be that this future
completes
when this callback is complete and this
way we
can create a workflow
so to implement this we can use uh our
promise object but for optimization
purpose to reduce the number of
allocations it's better to have
one type dedicated to this and so we
we're going to introduce a new type of
future that we're going to call
future continuation i'm going to copy it
here
so it's very simple uh it's inherit from
future
it takes the continuation and the parent
and store them and then it explores an
invoke method that is internal that's
very important
that calls the continuation and
transitions the future from
to completed so basically it's merged
the concept of future and promise into a
second class
mainly to reduce the number of heap
allocation and also to make some stuff
easier to implement later so once we
have that
we can go back to our continue
with method and implement it so it will
be something like that
we create our future continuation we
call an add continuation method that we
haven't implemented yet
and we'll return the future but if i
have only discontinued
then here let's say that i want to
return the value so say 10
i won't be able to because our only
continuous
return is non-general future and we have
no overload that
returns a generic one so we are going to
add this
so like this i declare
this overload so of course he knew is
that take a thunk
instead of an action this time and it
returns a generic feature
and so i'm going to copy paste the code
here
but it's not going to work because
feature continuation
is a non-general feature and here we
need to
return a generic one so we need a new
implementation
of future continuation so we are going
to do that
and here we have future continuation of
t which is just like future continuation
except that it inherits from future of t
and so it takes the continuation
and the parent and in the internal
invoke equals the continuation
assign the result to the future and
transition to complete it
so now i can just use my generic future
continuation
and it should work but then let's
imagine that i don't want to return 42
but i want to return
the value of the parent future times
uh i can do that because continuous is
only declared
on the non-general future so i need to
add overload
on the generic one so
we are going to do that right now so my
general future is right there
and so i need to continue with on this
class
and here you may be tempted to copy
paste this
but this is not going to compile because
future continuation
accepts an action or feature and here we
have an actionable feature of t
and so if you want to do things cleanly
you have to implement
not two types of continuation but four
different types of continuation and
that's what they did
in the dotted framework so in our case
we're going to cut corners
just to go faster and i'm going to
reuse the same future continuation but
introduce
a lambda that will cast the future to
future security
but by doing so i add a heap allocation
because of the closure
and so if you're worried about
performance you cannot do that
and that's why they didn't do that in
the detail framework
okay so i still need the one for that
routine the generic feature
and now we can finish implementing it so
we still don't have the add continuation
method so i'm going to implement it
and we just need to enqueue
the continuation to some internal queue
and i have to do here i will go back to
it later
and so i still need to introduce that
concurrent queue
so concurrent queue feature that i call
continuation
there we go and so uh
right there this works and we we have
our continuations that are included
and we still need to execute them when
our feature is completed
so i'm going to introduce an invoke
continuations method
i'm going to copy paste it right there
and the idea is that we just take
everything we have in the queue
and we call invoke honest but this
cannot work because
invoke is an internal method
that is declared on future continuation
and future continuation of t
and here we have a cure future so we
cannot use invoke
there are multiple ways to fix that for
instance we could
do some testing but we have potentially
four different types of contamination we
could use interfaces
but the way they did that in the net
framework is
by introducing an internal virtual
invoke method on the base feature
and then just overriding it when
necessary
right there and my other future
continuation is right there
so it means that if you call in work on
some kind of feature you will get an
exception but this should never happen
because
the method is internal and on our side
we are careful to
only call it when it makes sense we
still need to call in the continuation
some point so we're going to say
when i set is completed to true i'm
going to call invert continuations
like that and uh yes and the to do
so if i add continuation of feature that
is not completed
is going to be enqueued and then when we
transition to completed we call invert
continuation and we execute it
but if the future is already completed
when i call add continuation
then i'm going to enter it and never
execute it
because we've already called in the
continuation
so in that case i'm going to say okay if
the current future is already
completed so i directly invoke the
continuation
without unqueueing it
and with that we should have everything
we need so
i'm just going to put that in there
and i'm going to chain another feature
after that so continue with
here i'm going to say a second feature
and display the the result
and we're going to make sure that it's
working
and uh we see that done is displayed
right away because we are not blocking
the thread anymore
and then we see 42 and 84.
but we still have a problem let's say
that
i want to add a continuation to the
first feature
so i'm adding a continuation to the
feature that was returned by essing
method
and here i'm going to write a second
continuation
like this and then uh
i'm going to make the asynchronous
method slightly faster just to save time
and we will say that the first
continuation takes some time to run
and now if i run my program what is
going to happen is that
we have done instantaneously and then we
have a two second pers
and then we have a future completely
that is executed first
then second future and finally second
continuation
so second continuation had to wait for
those two to execute
before executing even though it should
have been able to run
as soon as the synchronous method
completed so what happened
the problem with our current
implementation is that we are calling
the continuations
in the same thread that completed the
promise
uh this is something in asynchronous
programming that we call inlining
and this is a very fine optimization in
some cases but
there are other cases like that where
this is not a
desirable behavior to work around that
we need to introduce a way to schedule
our continuation on another thread
but depending on the application they
may have a different requirements
for uh scheduling so we're going to
introduce an api for that
so i go back to my implementation and
i'm going to introduce
this api that we are going to call
future scheduler
and uh the idea is that we will
introduce a single method
that is q future and whenever you
implement your own scheduler you
override this method
and you get called back whenever there
is a future to schedule
and then it's up to you to pick when and
on what thread this future should
execute
so we are going to implement a scheduler
ourselves so this is a thread pull
feature scheduler so we're going to
schedule the future
on the thread pool we override the q
future
and here we're just going to schedule it
on the thread
and you may be thinking that it is going
to work but
um let's imagine that i'm here
i'm inside of my future library so i
have access to all the internals
but if i'm in my application so in a
different assembly
and i try to do the same thing then i'm
going to have a compilation
error here because invoke is internal
and we don't want to make invoke public
because
there are situations where we shouldn't
call invoke
so we want to present that ideally we
would need a way
for the user to execute the future that
was given to him
through the q future method but only
this one
and the way they fix that in the dotted
framework
is by introducing a protecting method
that we're going to call
execute feature which takes the future
and
here we're going to make some sanity
check to make sure that this feature
is the same as this one and then we call
invoke safely
sorry it should be on the base base
scheduler
there we go and so when we implement our
own scheduler instead of
invert we should do execute feature
and this should work as expected
so we still need to wire everything up
whenever we do continue with we enqueue
the future
but now we will now accept a feature
scheduler
and the idea that we enqueue the future
but we should
also enter the scheduler and one way to
do that
is to add the notion of scheduler to our
future continuation
and in fact it's even easier for many
reasons to add the notion of future
directly to the parent future
that's what they did in the data
framework the notion of scheduler is
backed directly into the task
so i'm going to add to our internal
constructor the scheduler i'm going to
store it
in a property
and then i'm just going to update all of
our constructors to make sure
we take the scheduler so i do that for
future of t
and i'm going to do that for future
continuation as well
so here i just take the scheduler and
then i call the base scheduler
and if the scheduler is null then i will
give future scheduler the default so i'm
going to add that in a second
there we go and then we are going to
define the notion of a default scheduler
just to make
thing easier so static read only
your scheduler default
and we return the thread through
scheduler
and now uh we should have pretty much
everything so we just need to replace
the parameter in all of our continuous
call
basically i take the scheduler and i
give it to the future continuation
and i do that everywhere so we're just
going to skip around it
there we go but
i'm still not using the scheduler so uh
to use it i'm going to add a helper that
i'm going to call a schedule and start
and what it does is asking the scheduler
to enter
the future and now every time i was
using invoke
i will be using schedule and start
instead
so if i forgot nothing and i run my
program
we see that second continuation appears
immediately
without waiting for the other
continuation to execute
so we've solved the scheduling problem
but we went from a situation where
everything was in line to a situation
where nothing is in line
it would be nice to have a situation in
between where we inline
only when it's safe so we are going to
add
uh the notion of inlining to our
schedule
so we will add a protected
internal virtual bull try
execute feature inline that takes a
feature
default implementation returns always
false
and then in the threat to scheduler
we're going to say
okay it's fine to inline
if we are currently on the threat pool
so if the current threat
is a threat to thread then we execute
the future
and we return true to say okay we've
inlined the future
otherwise we wrote on force so the idea
that
you implement this you get called
whenever there is a possibility to
inline your future
and then you take the decision to
execute it or not and it will turn
through if you did
or force otherwise and then we still
need to decide when it's safe
to call doing lining
and we will say that it's safe whenever
we have only one continuation
in our on our future so right there i'm
going to say okay if we have only one
continuation
then i take it i give it to the
scheduler and i ask do you want to
inline this future
and if the scheduler refuse then i just
schedule the
the future as usual and of course you
can think of many situations
where it's safe to inline the future or
not and in fact you have different rules
between dotted framework the plant core
and mono here we will only implement
this one
just to make sure that it's working i'm
going to add the dnxt
message right there so in lining
and if i run my program uh we see
second continuation future completed and
only there
i see in lining because this is the only
place in my workflow where i have only
one continuation
also i forgot what to do sorry about
that
right there in execute future we still
need the sanity check to make sure that
this feature
is the same as this one well now that we
have the notion of scheduler inside of
our future
we can just say okay if the scheduler
of the future is dif is different from
this
then it means that the user is trying to
do something funky
and we throw an exception okay
so at this point we have everything we
need from uh
the task so uh just to summarize
uh the type that we have implemented are
future
for task from s for task completion
source
future continuation for continuation
test from task
and as i explained there are four
different types of continuation
in the data framework and future
scheduler for task scheduler
and so now uh if you need to implement
your own scheduler for your.net
framework application
you should be able to understand what
you are expected to do instead
inside of task and try execute task in
line because they work the same way as
what i described
okay so we can't talk about
asynchronous programming in net without
mentioning async await
so i've got an api here with a few
asynchronous methods some of them
are private and the idea that
we wait for an asynchronous delay and
then we return
a half-credit value so 1
10 100 and do something else takes an
input and double it
and so in modern c-sharp you will be
able to write this
basically you will be able to write your
ma to mark your method as async
and then use the away keyword to change
your code
just like if you were writing
synchronous code
and then something magic happens at the
compilation
and it works and we're going to
re-implement that magic
so whenever you mark a method as async
the compiler is going to emit what we
call a state machine
so it's going to be a class that is
nested inside
of your parent class why is it nested
because it needs
to access to the same method that your
asynchronous method even if they are
private
and then it will declare a few field
first the state because it's a state
machine
then a reference to the instance of the
parent class
if the method is not static
then a move next method which will
contain
the core of the logic and then
it needs to declare a promise so a
public
promise of it here we return the future
of int
so we declare promise offense
and there we go and then the compiler is
going to rewrite
your uh collision method into this
listing sorry so first increase the
state machine
then it assign the this field
then it could move next and whenever
move next returns
it return the feature that is stated to
the promise
so it doesn't look like your original
method
at all and now from our code
we are not going to need this anymore uh
we can call
a new api dot core async we can
wait for it to complete
and then we can just display the result
so if i run this right now nothing is
going to happen because my state machine
is empty
and now we're going to implement it so
the state machine is basically a giant
switch case
so we switch on the state and the first
time
the state is zero so we update the state
so that the next time we call moon next
we will move to the next branch of the
switch
then we need to call uh do something
async one
and await it so we are going to say okay
this that do something asynchronous
which returns the future and we're going
to add a field to store it
like this
and then we need to wait for this
feature to be completed
so we are going to call continuous
and ask okay when this future completes
just call me back
call back the move next method and since
we've updated the state
when the future completes it will cause
move next and we will move to the next
branch of the switch statement
and here we can't do anything else so
we're just going to return that's
important
it means that we will freeze the thread
so here we will return
and at this point we will return the
feature to the client
so whenever you call an asynchronous
method is going to execute synchronously
until you get the first time you await
an asynchronous operation
and then is going to return to you
okay so the next time it's going to be
to be case one
so we update the state just like before
and so the future completed
and we need to assign this feature to
the i variable so we are going to add a
few fields
to our state machine to keep track of
the local variable
uh and i'm missing one of those there we
go
and i'm going to fetch the results of my
future and store it into i
like this and so now we've implemented
the first line
and we need to do the same thing for
every line of our
asynchronous method so here i'm just
going to copy paste stuff
so after that we can do something
essential bitcoin continue with and we
return
next case we phase the result into j we
could do something sm3
next case
uh we switch into k now we can do
something else async
and we give all the local variables that
we
stored on our state machine and the last
case is a bit different because we
it's the last one
and here we're going to complete the
promise which will
in turn transition the future to
complete it
and so now if i run my program
we wait for a while and here we see the
value so our method executed
properly so
there is a nice optimization that we can
do here
uh the problem that do something essay
will sometimes execute synchronously
and when that happens we still going to
call continuous which may schedule us to
another thread
only to be called back so it would be
nice if when this
executes synchronously we just directly
jump to the next state
of our state machine so we're going to
do just that so i'm going to say okay
this feature is completed
then go to case one
and then we do that for uh for every
branch
so uh to understand that because of that
uh if all of our away curl sorry
complete synchronously then our async
method will complete synchronously and
will not return
before the end because every time we
jump to the next case and we don't
return okay just making sure that i
brought nothing
okay so here we have a working state
machine and the one in the data
framework use the same principle
of course it's much more complex because
it has to deal with try catch block with
if
else with while loop and so on so there
are many more states
and it can jump back to previous state
and so on
but the basic principle is the same
but right now i can only await the
future
because my state machine only know how
to manipulate the future
it would be nice if we could just await
any arbitrary type
such as task or value task or even your
your own custom feature to do that we're
going to
uh introduce an abstraction we're going
to
called subtraction io waiter
which will define what we need to avoid
something
and here we're going to say okay what do
i need from the future
i need to know if it's completed i need
to change the continuation
and i need to fetch the results so i'm
going to add those three things
to my abstraction so get results
is completed and uncompleted to change
the continuation
then i'm going to introduce future
waiter
which is the implementation of io waiter
for our future so all it does is take a
feature
store it and then we just map every
method of the api
of the interface on our feature so
uncompleted is mapped on continuous
and once we've done that we can say that
the convention is that whenever you
await something
we will call get a waiter on that
something and we
expect to get an iota and then we know
how to use it
so here i will replace this by a future
waiter
and here whenever i await something i
use get a waiter
oh yeah and i also should add the
getaway to method sorry i'm skipping one
step here
so i add a get a waiter method to my
future
i write it as an extension method but it
could be a normal method it will work
the same
and when you call get a waiter we return
the new feature waiter for the future
so now i can use get the waiter and here
i'm just going to replace everything by
the api
of a get a waiter so uncompleted
and results become get result
so i'm just going to replace everything
i'm just
going to copy paste to go faster
like this so just it's the same set
machine except that i replace the car
with the ioh
api so making sure that i brought
nothing
and it's still working and so at this
point we can await
any type that uh define a get a waiter
method that returns an io waiter
so that's pretty nice but
we can await anything but we still have
to return the future
because we only know how to manipulate
these problems
so just like the waiter it would be nice
if we abstracted that
that we can return any arbitrary kind
of future so that we can return a task
value task you name it
just like before we're going to
introduce a new abstraction
and we are going to call that nasync
method builder
and we will call ours the future builder
and then we see what do we need from the
promise we need to fetch
the associated feature and we need to
complete it
we need only those two things so i'm
going to add those two things to my
future builder
so we create a promise we have a task
property which returns the future
and we have set results which complete
the promise okay
and i'm going to add one more thing
right now is my state machine that calls
uncompleted on the operator
i want to delegate that to the builder
so that it will give the builder a
chance for instance to log some stuff
or to save the state before yielding the
thread
it's just to make the api more powerful
so i will call this method await and
completed
and it will take an awaiter and a
state machine
and then the most basic implementation
we will just call the awaiter
and ask to call back the state machine
but right there we could
uh save the state or lock stuff or
whatever
so this is not going to compile i cannot
refer on the state machine because
every asynchronous method will have a
different state machine because it's
emitted at compilation time
for that we're going to introduce an
interface that we will call ising state
machine
and it has a movement x method and so
here i can expect an i asking state
machine
and this should compile and here i'm
just going to say that
i implement my async state machine
that i have future builder instead of my
promise
i will call it builder
and i just need to replace everything so
here we return
builder.task and uh
instead of feature that uncompleted we
will
be there that awaits and completed like
this
and in the end we will call a builder
that completes
that set result so just like before i'm
going to copy paste
there we go so here we call bill.search
result
and now just making sure it's still
working
and this is still working so right now
our state machine can
await any arbitrary type and return
any arbitrary type so it's pretty nice
from this point we're going to optimize
some stuff and
mainly i would like to reduce the number
of hip allocation because
uh when you allocate something on the
hip you could proceed on the gc
and it can uh cause unwanted poses
in the client applications so we start
by our builder
and we will make it a struct to remove
one allocation
you can't have initializers in the
industry but in any case i don't want to
manipulate promise because it will add
one heap allocation that we can remove
so instead we will directly manipulate
the future
and in the test property we will lazily
allocate
that feature so if it's not there i
create it as a librarian
and so in search results i'm going since
i don't have a promise i'm going to
manipulate directly the
the future it's okay because it's in our
library
and i use the test property so that it
gets allocated
lazily if it's not already allocated
and one more organization here when i
call await and completed
i expect an io waiter and my future
waiter is a struct
which means that it's going to be boxed
why because
structs are value types and interfaces
are reference type they are different
semantics and so for you to be able to
cast your struct to an interface
the runtime is automatically going to
box it which means going to make a copy
of it on the hip we can
avoid that by making our meta generic so
instead of expecting an io waiter
we expect a tier waiter where tier
waiter
is an eye waiter which looks dumb like
that
but by doing so you remove the hip
allocation you remove the boxing
so just making sure that it's still
working
still good so we're going to optimize
further
uh now let's have a look of our state
machine
um right now it's a class it would be
nice if it was abstract
so fun fact in the dotted framework if
you compile in debug
mode the state machine is a class and if
you compile in release
it's a struct that's because it's much
easier for the debugger to keep track of
it if it's a reference type
and so in debug mode it's sacrificing
the optimization just to make debugging
easier
so i cannot have initializer but i don't
care because
feature builder is a struct so i don't
need to new it
and that's it looks like it compiles
but if i run my code here i'm going to
wait forever because it's not actually
working
and so uh we're just going to add a few
breakpoints to see what's happening
so one here and one in uh when we
complete the builder
there if i run my program in debug mode
so here we see that call async returned
and we are waiting on the future
so far so good then at the other end of
the asynchronous workflow
we're going to call set results on the
builder which
will transition the future to completed
but here if we inspect underscore future
we can see that the value is null
so it's going to be lazily allocated
when we call the tax property
but that's really weird because we are
already waiting on the future at the
other side
so how can it be null well
this one is a bit hard to understand so
i prepared an animation for it
and so there we are so we have a very
accurate representation of the memory
with the stack on the left and the hip
on the right
and this is our code a bit blurry so we
create the state machine the state
machine is extract so it gets
allocated on the stack the future
builder is a struct as well so we get
nested inside of the state machine
that's how structs work in that path
then later on we call await and
completed and
here we're going to box our state
machine we're going to do so at two
places
first here because we cast it to an
interface so that's what i explained for
iowa this is going to
cause uh to cause boxing and
here which is less obvious why
we box here because we take a delegate
to an instance method of extract
the problem is that the struct leaves on
the stack and the stack we get
clear when the method return but
the delegates can live pretty much
forever
and can be called at any point in time
during the lifetime of the application
so by the time my delegate is going to
be called
my struct might not be on the stack
anymore which will cause us to reference
invalid memory
so to make this safer uh whenever you
take a delegate
to an instance method of extract the
runtime automatically box it
why is that a problem well when you bug
something
as explained the runtime is going to
allocate a chunk of memory on the hip
then it's going to make a copy of the
stack
to the hip and so at this point we end
up with two different state machines in
memory
then later on we are going to call wait
which will cause a lazy allocation of a
future
and this is going to be allocated on the
future builder that is on the stack
so the one on the left now has a feature
that has been lazily allocated
and then at the other end of the
workflow we're going to call move next
on the boxed state machine and later
we're going to call set result
again on the box state machine which
will cause the lazy allocation
of the future on the boxster machine but
then we end up with two different
features
and so if we complete the one on the
right the one on the left still isn't
completed
so how can we fix that well the most
obvious fix is to get rid of the boxing
and we can easily get rid of the first
box because we did that for iota we can
just make our method generic
the second one we can't get rid of it
it's a runtime limitation so we have to
live with it
instead right there we're going to force
the allocation
of the future so what does it change
well the idea that
we force the allocation of the future
while our state machine is still on the
stack
so now we have a feature in our future
builder
and then when we get to the next line
and we box the state machine we make a
copy of it
and so we make a copy of it with the
future inside of it
and so now if i call search result on
the right it
completes the one on the left because
future is a reference type and so both
of them refer on the same object
please note that it can only work
because future is a reference type
and that's why in data framework when
you use value task
which is a strict implementation of the
task if you await an asynchronous
operation
it will have to do a heap allocation
under the hood
precisely because of that problem
all right so uh we're going to implement
the fix that i mentioned
so i just need to go back to my builder
that is right there
uh i'm going to make it generic to
prevent the boxing
note that i also add the ref keyword i
didn't explain that
that's because now that i
expect a struct whenever you call a
method and give a stroke as a parameter
you make a copy of it and since we make
a copy of it
we end up in exactly the same problem as
we had
with boxing so by using the ref keyword
i make sure that we make we don't make a
copy of it
so here i need to force the allocation
of the task
the future sorry so i need to call the
task property
i cannot call an empty property like
that that's not by c-sharp
so i like to use the g6 use the gckpoli
method which is an empty method
just to make it valid but i could do
that and that would be the exact same
thing it's just a matter of style
and so if i run my program right now and
if i made no mistake hopefully
oh yeah since i added the ref keyword i
need to update
all the call sites to give the ref
parameter
so there are a few of them four of them
sorry
there we go so now if i run my program
and if i make no mistake
now this work and our state machine is
abstract
that's one last optimization i would
like to do
right now every time we call await
uncompleted we box the state machine
right there
but every time it's going to be the same
state machine so it would be nice if we
boxed it only once
and then we stored the box state machine
somewhere so we're going to implement
that
i'm going to add a field to store the
state machine like that
and then here i'm going to say okay if
state machine
is null then i box it
so to block it i just cast it to an
interface
with an equal inspector and then i store
it in my
underscore state machine field
and of course i call move next on the
box state machine
so i thought that was working and then i
added a diagnostic message
so right there i'm going to write boxing
and if i run this we see that boxing is
called is displayed every time we await
so our optimization is not working
which is really weird because it's very
straightforward if that machine is null
we assign it and so it shouldn't be null
anymore
so this one took me actually an entire
afternoon to understand
so i have an animation for it so
we have the same representation as
before with the stack and the hip
and this is our code so at this point we
have the state machine on the stack
and we get to this line where we're
going to box the state machine
and since we box it i've already
explained we make a copy of it
on the heap and then we are going to
assign
our underscore state machine with a
pointer to the box state machine
the problem is that we assign underscore
state machine to
this parameter so we assign it to the
state machine
that is on the stack okay
and then later we call the waiter on
completed and we return
so the stack get cleared move next get
called at some point
on the state machine on the hip and then
during the execution is going to be
unboxed
and we end up with a copy of the hip on
the stack
and then nothing reference the state
machine the box state machine anymore
and it's going to get garbage collected
and we get back to the initial situation
we are going to box the state machine
we are going to assign it to underscore
state machine but we assign it to the
one on the stack
and the problem is that we never assign
it to the one on the hip
so it's pretty much the same program as
we had with the future just previously
and so you may think we can fix that by
uh
making by boxing the state machine only
after
assigning the underscore state machine
field but we can't do that because to
ascend
assign the field sorry we need to box
the state machine first so it's a kind
of chicken and egg problem
to fix it we are going to use
this bit of code so let's see first we
block the state machine just like before
then we assign it to underscore state
machine just like before
and then we call set state machine on
the block state machine
and we give the block state machine as
parameter so that's
that looks weird so first is very
important to understand that we call set
state machine on the block state machine
so i call it on this one not the one on
the stack
then inside of set state machine we are
going to call
builder.setstatemachine since we are in
the boxed
state machine we will call a set state
machine on the boxed
future builder and then we just assign
the underscore state machine field and
so we end up with the underscore state
machine field that is
assigned inside of our box and our
optimizations we were from there
so we're just going to implement it
real quick so the idea is that right
there
i copy paste the same code as the slide
and so it means that we are going to
need a set stack machine method
on my builder so right there
add a set state machine on my uh is
instead machine here on my interface
i'm going to copy paste this like that
and now we need to implement it on the
actual state machine
so right there
and now if i forgot nothing if i run my
code
we see that boxing is displayed only
once and is still working
at this point we've implemented all the
features that are needed
to make i think a weight work in the
dotted framework
and to prove it i'm going to go back to
our future of t
implementation that is right there and
i'm going to add the async method
builder
attribute it tells the compiler whenever
i make an asynchronous method
that returns a feature use this builder
okay then i going to um
add the ideatific completion interface
to the
io waiter this is just the io waiter of
the total framework
and then i'm going to delete the iasing
state machine because it already exists
in the dot framework so here now we
reference the one that is in the dotted
framework
and i'm going to add a few things to the
builder because i took some shortcuts
so first i need to add a tweet method
which create a new builder that's all it
does
and we are going to add a staff method
which called
move next on the state machine so why
because i lied to you
here uh when you use the dotted compiler
what it does it doesn't call move next
on the state machine
it calls start on the builder which in
turn
called move next on the state machine
this is to give the builder
a chance to do some initialization or
change the state or change the thread
and so on
but right now we just call move next on
the state machine
and i'm going to add a set exception
method that we're not going to implement
because we don't
have exceptions in our future and last
but not least we're going to add a new
wait and save on completed
that i don't have time to explain but it
has something to do with
the execution context but here i just
call the traditional await and
and now complete i've done that i can
delete this
i can delete this and i can just
uncomment this method and it should
compile
and work just fine and so we see our
boxing once
and we have the expected result and so
we've reimplemented basically a single
weight
uh in the dotted framework
all right uh one last thing uh we cannot
talk about async
without mentioning the circulation
context and so
what is the synchronization context so
if you are
used to making a winform
or wpf application you may already know
that you can
only update ui controllers from the ui
thread
the circulation context is an
abstraction that allows you to
send your course back to the ui thread
to make your life easier basically
and so here i have a synchronization
context not going to show it
and instead of calling collecting like
this
i'm going to call it on the
synchronization context
so basically i use the post method or
and it says okay execute that call on
the ui thread
and then in collision i'm going to
instrument it
with the display current circulation
context method which name is
self-explanatory
and i'm going to run the code and here
we see that
the first time we are on our custom
synchronization context we are in the ui
thread
and then we await and then we are
outside of it
but because our future scheduler put us
back on the thread pool every time
and so if you are writing a ui it means
that right there
you can update your ui controls and
there
you cannot anymore even though you are
in the same method
so this is very error prone and so to
fix that
we would like to stay in the ui thread
for the duration of the method
so we're going to add this feature to
the feature waiter
so in the future waiter whenever it's
completed we use continuous
to call back so instead what we're going
to do is
first we capture the circulation context
and then in the continuous we're going
to post
the continuation back to the circulation
context if there was one
or if there's none we just resume the
execution normally
now if i run my code we see that we stay
on the synchronization context for the
entire while of the method
but so if you're a ui guy then you're
happy but
if you are writing a library then you're
not so happy because
your library is going to be hosted in
many different applications
and all of them might have have a
different secondation context
even custom one and so you don't want to
resume
execution in their circulation context
because it may have
softer rules for threading which
could cause dead blocks in your code
so basically we should add a way to opt
out
from this behavior so okay we are going
to update the waiter again
so i go back to the future waiter i'm
going to add
one parameter we're going to call it
capture context
and then we're going to say okay we
capture the synchronization context
only if capture context is true
otherwise we don't capture it
but then we have a problem uh when we
write our
asynchronous method we just say we await
that
and then the compiler is going to call a
get a waiter on whatever this petal
written
but we cannot give a parameter and so we
we cannot feed the value of
capture contacts we want to our feature
a waiter
so the way they fix this uh until here
yeah
and so here in the parameter let's get a
waiter we must choose
true or false but we cannot have both
so the way they fix that in the dotted
framework is by
introducing another type that we're
going to call configured feature
awaitable
and all is it is a struct that get
contains the future
and a value for capture context and it
exposes a parameter let's get the waiter
which return the future waiter with the
value we want
so how the how does that help us well
now that we have that
we can add an extension method so they
are here
that we're going to call configure
weight and configure weight
we'll take the boolean and create the
configure future awaitable with the
value we want
and then the state machine we call
getawaiter on that type
and get the future waiter that is
properly configured
so this is just a workaround for the
fact that whenever you await
a type you cannot give a parameter
to your awaiter so now let's say that
there's a second call i do configure it
first
oh sorry
so remember that configure weight does
not do
anything to the talk to the task all it
does is create an intermediary type
that will return a properly configured
awaiter that's all it does
and so if i run my program here we can
see that for the first two call
we are on the segregation context so on
the ui thread
and then we await we configure weight
first
and then we are back to the
straightforward
and that's exactly how configure weight
work uh
in the data framework and so you see
that if you do not use
a weight uh and more precisely if you do
not use
the uncompleted method of your operator
then configure weight will have no
effect at all
on your program all right so
that's it that's a lot of content for
just one hour
i hope you appreciated it and maybe we
have a bit of time for
questions and otherwise i will be
hanging around on slack
to answer them